Biden says the other day this is after
the shooting he says quote unquote
transgender people shape our nation's
soul in official Proclamation let me
just read this real quick go ahead he
issued an official Proclamation
declaring the transgender American shape
our nation's soul and establish an
American holiday relating to this group
you reissued this on March 31st
transgender Americans shape our nation
so proudly serving in the military
curing deadly diseases holding elected
office running thriving businesses
fighting for justice raising families
and much more all right listen uh Joe
Biden transgender people are 0.5 of 1 of
our nation yeah okay do they deserve to
be treated like human beings do they
deserve to be of course respect sure but
who shapes our nation's Souls our
families our people with kids or people
that have grandparents and aunts and
uncles and families and kids and
American family values that is our
nation's Soul yeah okay transgenders
might be a sliver of what's going on
here but they are not the ones shaping
no our nation's soul I agree and this
pandering to the woke left so they can
[__] get point five percent of
people's votes yeah is nonsensical to me
100 and I totally understand to revisit
this exactly why Riley Gaines is like
hey
um just a female swimmer over here
trying to compete against women yeah and
you got this dude over here who's six
five Lurch beating me it's like this
doesn't make sense any sense and it's a
back to back credit this [__] just
doesn't add up yeah and you made it I
mean made a great Point Adam where are
all and I'm being genuine I'm calling
them out we're all the genuine feminists
the Lena uh Dunham Alyssa Milano the
Beyonce's all the where you at you have
like it you morons it doesn't bother you
that like like for instance look at this
picture right here yeah yeah let me I
mean like you know how they say A
picture says a thousand words like
that's just look at the picture yeah
like the lady on the left wink wink yeah
it's so absurd they shared a locker room
all these folks did and that guy still
had equipment so he was still packing
heat yeah he has unbelievable and Tom
Tom you have children Pat you have
children let me ask you a question you
guys have Rob tried to zoom in yeah
volleyball trans volleyball you guys
have you have children Pat you have a
daughter Tom you have daughters so Pat
what how do you feel what do you do you
have a daughter right Santa you have
your daughter date she she works her
whole childhood you have her in swimming
she busts her ass she's honing her crap
she's sacrificing going out with her
friends no movies no boyfriend her
entire youth is it's she sacrificed to
be the best swimmer then she's about to
go to college and loses a scholarship
her place because there's a dude with
testicles that wants to be in there and
nobody says anything people are praising
them what do you do as a father what's
your reaction what do you do oh you
you're gonna have to speak up and say
something about it and and defend your
daughter who's been training hard and
you know going do your part to get
involved on a board and have a voice and
call the people out you can't sit on the
sidelines be quiet about it you have to
create a voice and say something about
it and defend your daughter because this
is demoralizing to your daughter this
this is if you don't have that
conversation with her this is very
demoralizing it's surprising that the
feminists are are defending this they
and they're or they're quiet but I but
but I'm so like for me Tom you wanted to
say something you have two girls
yourself as well so what would you say
about what Vinnie just said right there
so I think I step back at it and I look
at it and I've been quiet for a few
minutes here uh intentionally I step
back and I look at it and I say okay
there is a new
entitlement group out there there is a
new marginalized group and it's called
trans and the media will cancel you cost
you your job cost you your reputation
and attack you if you go against the
narrative that trans is a new
marginalized discriminated against group
so you have true feminists that fought
like hell for Title IX Title Nine you
know in college sports said that women's
college sports should get the same
funding and opportunity as men college
sports thank you very much and that
there were some sports that will be
unique to men football and there are
going to be some sports that were unique
to women ballet and dance you know
ballet there's dance but there's you
know what I'm talking about so number
one that's where it started right now
you have I haven't spoken to any college
coach I've ever seen I've asked this
question and I said should we should we
respect that for whatever reason they
are declaring themselves trans Well yeah
if that's surrendered okay but if
they're gonna say that and a male is
going to say I identify as female uh
okay but but still we run a blood test
and everything you got your testosterone
everything like this I'll tell you what
we fought like heck for Title IX to give
women the opportunity all you men that
want to compete in division two of men
you compete against yourselves
transcompete against trans leave natural
men or what they call CIS men and leave
CIS women to themselves and let the
trans compete against trans because it
is not equal it says Rob there is a an
article
and this is serious because there is
different physiological things look at
the size of the swimmers size 13 feet
find me a woman with size 13 feet you'll
find one in the USA female swimmer with
a size 13 foot men they're all size 13
14 and 15 and they have longer arms they
are mechanically Superior in the water
they're just mechanically Superior now
look at this trans high school
volleyball player male who wanted to be
known as a female uses a vicious Spike
which hindered the female opponent in a
highlight reel and so then guess what
they did here there's North Carolina
right North Carolina said stop scroll
down Rob trans
trans men cannot compete with women
because of the difference in size and
strength
let's let trans compete against trans
women over here trans over here men over
here this guy knocked her freaking out
he knocked her out this is a man
so you're saying have a trans League
Time watch this one
is that a guy
no they're about to there's another clip
apparently that girl to the left is Gap
is about to get oh oh dude this cat is
oh that's a guy that's a guy that's a
dude that's right all the guys got it
nuts and all ladies and gentlemen wow
yeah well I'll say one thing about this
the speed that they've looked at it the
speed off the spike and the the level of
of jumping was different and so how can
you say so what do I say first of all I
see it as a form of cheating I see it
absolutely it's affordable cheating of
using the trans excuse to go win the
NCAA tournament Leah I'm talking to you
first second the NCAA after all these
years of Title IX we're completely
turning our backs on all the progress we
made for women let the trans compete as
trans let women compete as women let men
compete as as men at the school's got
enough budgets they can have trans team
great otherwise go raise the money for
your team just like regular teams do and
I see it as a form of cheating and so
what do I do if my kids I talk to my
daughters there's going to be cheating
people are going to want to cheat don't
be one of them and don't be don't be
discouraged after the fact you're going
to be discouraged in the moment you're
going to feel ripped off you're going to
feel emotions you're going to feel
cheated you're going to feel robbed
you know Bailey's team for golf lost the
Texas state championship because one of
her players was baited into what's
called not moving a mark back on the
green baited on the last hole it was a
two-stroke penalty and they lost by one
and I said you know what you have to
carry Bailey you have to carry the fact
that you won on the course all the
practice all the effort all the energy
all the dedication all the the things
winning your league winning your region
winning your District then winning your
region going there you won the Texas
State Golf Championship as a team that
you were baited now was the the penalty
was appropriate but you were that player
was baited and that's not right and they
all suffered the indignity of the
opposing coach saying I never saw it but
on the 17th and 18th green you had
Parents with camera phones all over the
place saying baloney that's you right
there what do you mean never saw it
those are your arms cross with your
coach visor quietly looking at your
player making a putt that's you yeah and
so listen
the cheating part of it it's gonna
happen in life don't let that be you
allow your emotions to come to the
surface because they're normal human
emotions don't suppress your emotions
I'll just I'll just let my final
thoughts number one shout out to Bailey
yeah
hello broker out there prediction time
so I guess I'd gone prediction okay uh
everything the at the end of the day I
think there's going to be some sort of
come to Jesus jump the shark moment
where we're like we can't look past this
anymore and it's not going to be in
sports like swimming or volleyball or
tennis or golf or you're not competing
physically against the other person yeah
unfortunately the sad reality this is
gonna happen in a [__] boxing ring or
a wrestling match where some
trans Dude shows up and beats the living
[__] death out of some chick it's gonna
be a permanent and she's gonna get a
concussion brain hemorrhage die he might
rip her limbs off and beat her with her
limbs I don't know what kind of gorilla
[__] might happen by the way but
unfortunately that's what might happen
by the way you're you're absolutely
right okay so for me when when one of
our sales guys or sometimes the kids
come up with an idea that I know it's a
bad idea sometimes I let him do it and
I'll say okay yeah you know what go
ahead and do it good do it do it and see
what happens okay so they'll go and
they'll do it and then all of a sudden
they'll be like hey you know uh uh it
didn't work I'm like yeah yeah that's
good now you know it doesn't work so go
back to what does work instead of going
to sometimes you have to allow bad ideas
to take effects for us to eventually see
the data and say this didn't work so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you